Hey guys, let's meet Jason
here with the Jubilee Project.
Hope you guys are all doing well.
This is not the video actually for
the five K as we haven't run it yet.
We're going to be running on
Saturday, which is luck. Uh,
but the reason for this video is
actually to put a date on your calendar.
And that day is April 8th,
2010 April 8th is a day without
shoes sponsored by toms shoes.
And the idea is that they want to get
people around the world to spend a day
without shoes.
Like this can be your entire day,
this can be a portion of
your day, um, whatever.
But the reason is to grow awareness
for the millions of children throughout
developing countries who
grow up without shoes.
And apparently this causes a lot of
serious problems for them growing up.
So I thought that I
would be participating.
I would love for you to join me and
the millions or I'm not sure at the
thousands of people around the world
who are participating as well. Uh,
there's more information at this link
at this video, but please, please,
please, uh, send me a comment. Send me
a message if you'd like to participate,
and we'll make a nice
little video as well.
And we'll post it up for the jubilee
project. But think about it. The Thursday,
April 8th, I'm going to be spending
my day without shoes at New York.
Uh, I'm not sure if I can
do that yet in the office,
but I'm gonna figure that out.
But the rest of the day, if not,
at least in the office, will be spent
without shoes and a, if you do it too,
maybe you can make a nice
little compilation video,
but please let me know if you're
interested. It should be a great time.
Take care guys.